bonsoir les auteurs de la prise d'otage
au palais de justice de nantes ont
libéré tout à l'heure les étudiants en
droit qu assister au procès de georges
courtois ainsi que les trois
journalistes qui étaient présents mais
ils détiennent encore une quinzaine de
personnes dont le président de la cour
d'assises de loire atlantique
le commissaire broussard et le préfet de
loire atlantique ont pénétré dans la
salle d'audience il tente actuellement
de négocier avec les malfaiteurs ce sont
les dernières informations concernant
cette affaire que nos confrères de
nombreux vont nous raconter dans
quelques instants
cette prise d'otage je vous le rappelle
a commencé ce matin vers 11 heures elles
durent donc maintenant depuis plus de
huit heures un homme a fait irruption
devant le palais de justice de nantes
et il l'a et ses îles à désarmer un
policier qui était présent et ensuite à
distribuer les revolver aux deux
prévenus qui devait être jugé tout de
suite nous allons reçoit en train de
dire que si jamais ça devait mal se
passer il ya des gens qui sont dehors
tout autour du palais de justice est
très intervenir avec aussi des grenades
qui
envoyer ses grenades dans tous les
les restaurants les bars les endroits
publics de langue ce soir à soi c'est
plutôt pour montrer
mon avis qu'ils sont forts alors qu'en
fait ils sont complètement isolés à
l'intérieur a conclu mme été entendue
vers 15h30 à l'extérieur
et courtois qui est sorti avec une otage
une fit une petite étudiante
il daterait devant elle il avait sa
manière à la main et
la fée son avocat quitter pas mon devoir
de le souligner à quelques temps et puis
comme il a vu un
la tête d'un policier qui dépassait il à
iliad il a tiré
la balle et la balle est allée se ficher
dans une des colonies
de la salle des pas perdus et qu'ils ont
des moyens de pression pour te faire
revenir quand tout ça non ils peuvent
avoir de gros moyens de pression pour le
faire rester concerné non non enfin cela
dit dernières interventions qu'ils ont
fait j'avais
aussi un pistolet à
et ben 20 cm de mon visage mais ils sont
radins de vinassan véritablement avant
de vous sont beaucoup plus menaçant avec
un des témoins du procès qui est encore
dans la salle et courtois dit que très
certainement il
il n'y aurait pas pour lui une solution
définitive en tout cas qui resterait
certainement marqué parce que ça veut
dire à quiconque de blessés parce
quelqu'un qui a fait une déposition
contre biya pendant le procès ce qui
confirme ce qu'on pensait ce matin ce
sont quand même assez nerveuse huawei
soit il est en plus mal pas l'impression
qu'on a eu 20 50 et 100 jours un peu
plus nerveux
et il a demandé que justement à chaque
fois j'aurai toujours la question qu'est
ce que vous voulez ou
deux voitures
urgence particulière ils disent nous on
fera connaître nos décisions en temps et
mais en voulu
ouais c'est tout ils ont ils ont aussi
aussi quand même si en ce qu'on a ce qui
nous ont demandé c'est donc le préfet
vienne et mons arqués qui est sur place
al commissaire moulin
maintenant je prends ça vient d'être
acceptée est-ce que vous avez
l'impression presque gécamines et maman
je crois qu'ils voudraient partir avec
la nuit ans puis 500 m la police parce
qu'il aurait beaucoup de difficultés
pour des
bernard dussol et son équipe sont à
l'intérieur de la salle avec les
preneurs d'otages ce qui explique qu'il
ait pu à l'occasion d'une sortie faire
cette conférence de presse de
journaliste de presse océan et de
ouest-france prise en otage également ce
matin viennent d'être libérés à leur
tour et puis nouvelles menaces de
courtois il aurait aidé complices à
l'extérieur capable d'agir en force au
cas où au cours de leur fuite
la police intervenait georges courtois
34 ans apparaît comme le meneur il avait
exigé dès ce matin la présence de la
télévision pour faire une déclaration
quel effet ça vous fait elle plus pour
juger quelqu'un pour finalement jouer en
position d'être jugé à votre tour
qu'est ce que ça vous fait madame
vous savez la chef
si vous voulez lien ce qu'il faut bien
savoir également c'est que ce qui me
concerne personnellement j'ai attendu
deux années ainsi que monsieur lionel
pour pouvoir réaliser cette opération
monsieur kalt king quant à lui attendu
cinq années pour pouvoir réaliser cette
opération
par conséquent je pense que les forces
de police peuvent attendre quelques
minutes quelques heures quoi enfin
disons quelques minutes les exigences
seront donc formuler clairement sans
équipe il convient pour les forces de
police
il conviendrait aussi qu'ils arrêtent de
téléphoner un bien puisque j'ai dit que
ils n'ont pas nous appeler c'est nous
qui les appelants faut pas renverser les
rôles quand même bien il conviendrait
par conséquent ainsi que l'a dit
monsieur varin premier substitut que les
forces de police entendent avec une
grande attention les exigences qui
seront formulées jeudi au nom d'allah et
d'autres fait en anglais l'islam au nom
de la nation arabe et au nom des
opprimés de tous les prix j'ai de faire
le soutien de mes deux camarades ici
présents pour conduire cette opération à
son terme
trois hommes on le voit déterminés prêts
à tout maintenant alors qu'ils sont
georges courtois et ses complices on a
parlé jérôme yeux clairs et on l'on a
entendu il ya un instant d'idéologie
intégristes comme moteur de cette action
eh bien parlons tout d'abord de georges
courtois le chef cet homme âgé de 36 ans
comparaissait devant les assises de
loire-atlantique depuis hier avec un
complice pour divers hold up c'est un
habitué des salles d'audience et des
prisons sa première condamnation il a eu
à l'âge de 17 ans son itinéraire c'est
celui de bien des délinquants parents
alcooliques scolarisation difficile ces
jours multiples en maison de
redressement dès l'ouverture de son
procès hier il s'est présenté comme une
sorte d'anarchiste de ravachol rejetant
une société qui ne lui a rien donné et
donc à laquelle il ne doit rien
revendiquant avec force la profession de
malfaiteurs et affichant le plus grand
mépris envers les juges les médecins et
autres experts il voulait assurer
d'ailleurs hier lui même sa défense il a
préparé en prison une licence en droit
son complice patrick thiollet âgé de 24
ans
montré hier tout aussi hardy mais d'une
personnalité quand même beaucoup moins
forte
enfin karim kalki qui a apporté les
armes permettant cette prise d'otages
est originaire du maroc
il est âgé de 35 ans il avait été
condamné en 83 à cinq ans de réclusion
criminelle pour un hold up dans un
bureau de poste
on ne sait pas s'il a bénéficié d'une
remise de peine ou d'une permission il
ne se réclament ils se réclament du
mouvement palestinien abou nidal ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il affirme
appartenir à un réseau palestiniens en
83 lors de son procès il se disait et
membre du front de libération de la
palestine mais un avocat du barreau de
nantes qui le connaît doute de son
appartenance à la résistance
palestinienne
il le considère néanmoins comme un
individu nerveux et dangereux